yes yeah you know and it's funny because
we talk about like who bought the story
and I feel like I bought a lot of the
story for years you know I I really did
I was like I was somebody like I came
out of college and I was like I really
didn't want to work that hard I really
didn't in fact I got offered a great job
with Lancome when I first came out in
makeup company and they were like you
have to travel and I was like oh no I'm
not traveling for work I don't want to
do that I want a sunbathe on the back
you know I want to have my Summers but I
did buy a lot of the story of like don't
lean on a man like it's dangerous to
lean on a man like you've gotta like it
was like an expectation that Society had
that I was gonna follow some sort of
work path so I think it's interesting
like to see all of these women that do
that and then land I'm trying to like
shake them like is this something you
really want or is this something that
you think you're being told that you
should want but in reality inside you're
like that's not for me